dallas cowboys have a great receiver
tomorrow cooper they want to sign to a
new contract chris they want to get
quarterback dak prescott signed a new
contract they want to get running back
ezekiel elliott who's still holding out
signed a new contract owner jerry jones
says it'll happen there literally is no
concern on my part at all about any time
frame it'll happen the results are too
good for them and too good for the
cowboys think about it now the results
are too good for them and too good for
the cowboys that always happens when
it's that good for both of us all right
that sounds good but ezekiel is in
mexico for crying out loud yeah so
when do you get it done if you're so
concerned it's gonna get done if you're
so confident it's gonna get done
i think the sooner you get it done chris
the better yeah
no question about that i mean you want
ezekiel elliot there get him going with
a team so you can kind of get a look at
what your team is going to be in
totality but uh jerry jones has been
saying the right things and he's saying
this to keep the positive vibes out
there for the football team to where
they're not questioning it or or
anything like that and he's kicking
keeping dak prescott and amari cooper
calm about their situations i think zeke
happens here in the next two or three
weeks i really do uh dak will happen
shortly after that and amari cooper that
might not be after the season maybe late
in the season whatever it may be but i
do have faith that they'll get it done i
mean dallas and jerry jones and the
family there uh throughout the years the
t the players that have contributed and
played at a high level they've done
their best to keep those guys wearing
the star on their helmet
well you say jerry jones has been saying
all the right things but he did take
some criticism last week when he
suggested that the cowboys don't really
need ezekiel elliott in order to be
successful right so i i i here's what i
think may have happened yeah i think
they were so stunned when he held out
that a lot of the stuff we got last week
was just kind of knee-jerk bluster right
and now that it's all settled in they've
maybe crunched some numbers they've
gotten to a point where they're
confident that they can make offers that
will be attractive to these guys and now
it's just a process of how best to put
those cards on the table to get the guys
to take whatever it is the cowboys have
decided they're going to pay them i
would think a lot of that's true you're
right got into the nitty-gritty of the
details numbers how they can make it
work too and you know again he's also
with that comment last week trying to
say you don't need the rushing title
leader to win a super bowl he's trying
to tell the rest of this team hey i got
confidence here we got a good team here
not one guy's gonna make us or break us
just in case it did filter into the
season or week one or week two or
something like that he wants the team to
feel that the jones family and the rest
of the organization feels that this team
can win even without zika eliot which is
the right thing to say either way but
you know i think ultimately they realize
what they got in zika elliott and what
he means to this offense and team and
and they'll find a way to get him more
money than todd gurley got in his last
contract extension
it could be that dak prescott's the
hardest one to sign to a long-term
contract because i do not see him biting
at all on this idea that he should take
less simply because he's the quarterback
of the dallas cowboys his agents clearly
do not care about that they get a
percentage based on what he gets period
and i think dak has it in his head i'll
never forget when you were asking him
about oh you don't seem like a selfish
guy you take a team friendly deal and he
gave you that side eye he gave you that
look and say hey don't don't don't get
in the way of me and my money and i
think dak prescott understands number
one he's a good quarterback number two
he's only getting better and number
three time's on his side if they don't
sign him now it may be a lot more
expensive next what do you think he'll
settle for you know what is it what's
the number you know just like aaron
garoppolo deal garoppolo
but yeah but but real money five years
27.5 million a year which will push the
new money average north of 30 million
yeah but i think the garoppolo's deal
same deal give it to dak prescott we'll
see the cowboys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports